- I'm a normal guy, a simple guy,
but I'm going to change the world.
I lost my wife in 95,
was alone with four children, no money.
The only thing that I found
relief in was in cold water
and breathing exercises.
I'm a messenger, by the way.
I'm a man on a mission.
And I don't stop until
we have no war anymore,
no disease and no depression.
Yes.
(clapping)
(upbeat music)
- What's up Believe Nation.
I am at the Evergreen Brickworks
here in Toronto, Canada.
I'm about to go do Wim
Hof's full day seminar
on breathing and ice baths.
I'm excited and I'm nervous for it.
We're going to hopefully have a
chance to talk to Wim as well,
and learn about his story.
It's May 20 when I'm recording this,
my birthday, and so we're
going to see what Wim
has to offer and hopefully
have fun in the cold bath.
(peaceful music)
- Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you.
Hello.
- [Man] We are ready for a great day.
That's the ice pool.
- [Wim] That's the ice pool.
That's the pool.
- Wow.
- [Wim] It's just getting going.
Get everyone.
- I love it.
- Yes, yes.
Let's make it a good story.
- We live in a world
where there's all kinds
of false healers and fake
alternative medicine programs
you can sign up for, it's
a rare moment in history
when someone comes along who
can perform real miracles
with real evidence to back them up.
Wim Hof has defied logic
time and time again
and always under scientific scrutiny.
He holds the world record for being able
to be submerged in ice
for almost two hours
without his core body
temperature changing.
He's climbed Mount Everest in
nothing but a pair of shorts,
and run a marathon in the desert
without drinking any water.
He's even proven in a laboratory setting
that he can withstand illnesses
using the power of his mind.
But he's not a freak of nature.
According to Wim, anyone
can do what he can do.
They just have to learn his method,
the Wim Hof method.
Using a combination of cold
immersion, breathing techniques,
and mental focus, anyone
can accomplish feats
that were previously
thought to be impossible.
- So before getting into it,
I want to tell you how I found you.
So, I used to always get sick, always.
- Ah.
- I was always,
and I always believed
that if you were sick,
don't come close to me,
'cause I'm going to get sick.
So on my team, if people were sick,
like, stay home, don't come to
me, you're going to get sick.
Then in January I got really, really sick,
five days, just straight
hiccups, constantly,
hiccups, hiccups, and then I decided
I'm never going to get sick again,
and I had to figure out
a way never to get sick,
and then I stumbled across your work
and what you were doing, said,
I'm going to give it a shot.
And since then, I haven't
gotten sick since January.
- Aha, hey, right on, man.
- To May 20th.
- Way to go man, way to go, way to go.
That's cool.
(laughing)
(chanting)
(cheering)
- Good evening, hello, yes.
- Explain the mission.
Why are you doing this,
why it's important to you,
it's not just about
setting the world records,
but why do you do this?
- Yes, as I've said, I
did a lot of stuff outside
in nature, 'cause I felt this
disconnection from nature
inside from the soul itself.
Soul is not able to express and
you can see it in the world.
Full of depression and
autoimmune diseases,
cancer, all those things,
anxiety, so nobody knows
actually, it's because of
the disconnection of nature.
So resulted in me in an awkward feeling,
I don't know what there is,
but there's more than meets the eye.
We going to show all those things,
native spirits had to subdue a
couple of hundred years here,
now they are coming back through us,
through the love, making sense
that Mother Nature is back.
I'm going into a soul search.
And that brought me to
all kinds of traditions,
esoteric disciplines,
languages, religions,
debates about philosophies,
cultures, anything, you know?
But in the end, it didn't connect with me.
That's where the cold water came in.
And the cold water is
merciless but righteous.
- Okay.
- So, boom, hey,
you got to be there.
- Right.
- But little by little, you
begin to wake up to that,
what you feel inside,
it's beginning to wake up
a real primordial, disconnection
is beginning to connect
to your consciousness,
brain, body connection.
It was in the books, it was not there.
And now we change the
books, in the university
and all of the story began
just in fucking freezing water.
(laughing)
And that after a lot of
esoteric disciplines,
philosophies, traditions,
languages, religions,
doctrines, yoga, kung fu,
anything I could get my hands upon,
and do it, I did it.
(clapping)
But that, it could not
bring that connection,
which I was looking for.
I wanted to know the
purpose of the soul itself,
so I went finally came
in concert with nature
and found attracted to ice water.
Severe, aggressive impact on you,
but I felt just beautiful,
correct, when I got inside
the water, and began to breathe.
And I felt without words, this is it.
The first time I went under the ice,
water is as sharp as needles.
I saw this as a big, huge sharp diamond.
At 35 meters, I lost
sight, because the retina,
it froze, I couldn't see nothing.
I couldn't breathe, of course.
And then, my consciousness succumbed
into a lower consciousness.
This is survival.
So the story begins with a feeling,
and I want you to feel with me.
So let's breathe.
(inhales)
Let it go.
Fully in.
Don't ask yourself how.
Just always say, use any hole you got.
(laughing)
Get it in, let it go.
Ice water, it's fresh in
here, take it fully in.
Halt and swim with me.
Swim, come on.
Move your arms.
It's the hello one.
This is Mother Nature.
Swimming into her, rebirth,
awakening the deepest within ourselves.
I do not fear death.
I fear not to live fully.
If I live fully, I'm not into death.
I'm living.
The thing is, I lost over
there the fear of death.
And that's where I found it.
The fear of death no longer.
And that made me able to
do very strange stuff.
Like climbing Mount Everest
in shorts to death zone,
Kilimanjaro in record times,
swimming under the ice, standing
for two hours in the ice,
hanging by one finger in
the mid-winter, one mile,
climbing all kinds of
mountains barefoot in the snow,
staying outside all night
in freezing temperatures
in nothing but shorts,
'cause you learn to deal
with the elements of nature,
and then you find out that the inner power
of the physiology both through
the brain body connection
is so much more than we
ever thought possible.
It's about confronting yourself
with the cold, the cold
is a natural element
able to bring you right down to your core,
the depth of the mystery
itself, called life.
And loving it.
So there I was, Mount Everest,
this is about 7060 meters
there, there I was,
sitting around, but there
I was, in the middle of it,
I didn't know where I was,
at 6000 so much meters, I was lost.
I was lost.
But not lost inside.
This connection was there.
I felt light.
I felt no paranoid or anxiety.
I felt okay.
It's where I found, had
found, not in the books,
once again, confidence and belief.
It was really opened me up, I could climb
the Mount Everest, I just had a good time
for the rest of the days I was there.
And now, after doing 26
of those world records,
about numerous more
challenges, I've gotten
encountered with scientists,
and then it came about
that I was awakening,
stimulating, and influencing
systems within the body,
they thought of not being
able to be influenced or
connected with for humans.
They thought, hey, you
must cannot just tap in,
it's autonomic nervous system,
but autonomy can process
outside of our world.
Brain body connection,
remember, connection
and there it is, and
now I'm able to connect,
enter, and make a difference,
and that's what I did in those studies.
- [Narrator] Wim's
mission is to use his body
as a laboratory, to revolutionize
our understanding of physiology.
In 2011, he was injected with a bacterial
endotoxin in an experiment
that challenged our
understanding of the nervous system.
In normal humans, the
injection should cause
a strong immune response,
leading to fever,
chills, and headaches.
But not in Wim.
It appeared that he was somehow able
to suppress his immune response
by making his body secrete adrenaline,
suggesting that his method can allow us
to influence our immune system at will.
Scientists thought he might
just be a freak of nature.
So to further prove this theory,
they performed this same experiment
on 12 subjects Wim had trained in Poland,
and the same thing happened.
- Proof they only got
after competitive study
with groups, so I took on a full group,
I trained them, four days,
to get into the autonomic
nervous system and all those things,
and they got administered
with the bacteria
and as well, all within
a quarter of an hour
entering into the systems.
And now we are getting somewhere.
Power of the mind.
Yeah, we are dealing
in modern day society,
we can go to the moon, we can go to Mars
and everywhere, but we cannot tap
into the depths of ourselves
and make a difference
with deep depression,
anxiety, fear, trauma, PTSD, anything.
We don't control our mind.
We are not able to embrace
the power of the mind
while the mind is ongoing, going, going.
Doesn't let us feel complete,
it is there all the time,
now we turned the wheels.
- Normally, it's very
difficult to increase
your adrenaline levels by your own will.
Adrenaline is released
by the autonomic nervous
system, and autonomic means
you cannot voluntarily
influence it, so if you walk outside
and you are robbed on the street,
you will have a heart rate
of 160, your blood pressure
will be sky high within seconds.
But if I ask you now to
increase your heart rate,
you cannot do that.
You cannot voluntarily modulate that.
And with the techniques
of Wim Hof, we showed
that he was able to
increase his adrenaline
levels to very high concentrations,
even higher than people
that go bungee jumping
for the first time.
- They saw me doing all
kinds of strange stuff
because what I was doing was not possible
by the physiologists, and I did it,
and so let's give him a shot,
and they gave me a shot.
And so there I was, I proved it,
and then I told, listen,
I'm not the only one.
Everybody is able to do this.
Everybody here is able to do this.
What?
How much training these people need?
A year, a year and a half?
Before they are able to do do a little bit
what you are able to do, what you showed?
I said, 10 days.
Just shook at that, like this, 10 days.
And only became four days.
And these guys, I took them to my place
in Poland in the mountains,
on the shadow side, it's
really cold out there.
But very warm on your heart.
Day four, without prior
experience in the cold,
they were able to go in
shorts up the mountain,
minus 10 to begin with,
up to the top, minus 27.
And there we danced the
uh, uh, the Harlem Shake.
(laughing)
So I knew then, these guys are ready.
They got the mindset,
they got the way natured
meant it to be.
Minus 27, that's powerful.
No, that's you.
That's your power, inside.
Realigned.
It's your mind being able to believe
you are able to conquer by connection
the way Mother Nature meant it to be
inside with about any system we got.
Now people who suffer from depression,
anxiety, fear, from all
those, PTSD, trauma,
they are living under constant stress.
And they are not able to break the loop.
Now I showed how to break the loop.
I'm messenger, by the way.
I'm a man on a mission.
And I don't stop until
we have no war anymore,
no disease, and no depression.
(clapping)
'Cause the most valuable, yes.
(cheering)
- For the people who are coming,
- Yeah.
- For the people coming,
for the people watching this video,
what's the message that
you hope they take away
from experiencing some Wim Hof today?
- Inside's and confidence that we are
very capable of bringing
back the inner power,
realized to become happy,
strong, and healthy.
Far more than ever
before thought possible.
So that's it.
Feeling is understanding.
So once the sense gets to the mind,
then it's going to open
up this thing called hope.
And that hope this time
is going to pay off.
It just a matter of a little practice
and I'm going to show how to
change the chemistry inside,
and then to battle one of
the most severe aggressive
impacts on the body, ice
cold water, and feel well.
And not only feel well,
feel a little bit depressed,
because there is no bathing dock inside.
(laughing)
Hammer time.
- All right, I'm looking forward to it.
Thank you for the time, I'm
looking forward to the session.
- Hey, cool, cool,
cool, schooling the gan.
(laughing)
Cool.
Ah, nice.
Aha, she just loves me.
I love this.
We move the hands to
make a circular movement.
I do, use the voice,
like they use it in Japan
with the (speaking in a foreign
language) the end to end.
(shouts)
(grunting)
Come on, no inhibition.
(everyone shouting)
Okay, nice.
Nice going.
(cheering)
Okay, let's begin and start breathing.
Lie down, sit down, stand on your head,
doesn't matter what you do,
just relax the body.
Fully in, belly, chest, into
your head, and let it go.
Belly, chest, head, letting it go.
That feeling, as simple as it is, we lost.
Too much neurology going on.
We think, we think better,
but yes, there is nothing
more than life itself.
This Sunday, it's happening anyway.
And there we go, fully in, let it go.
You become light-headed, loosen the body,
tingling, it's all all right.
Letting in, let it go.
Your belly, chest, and
even into your head,
you're able to store up
oxygen and letting it go.
Here comes the last one.
Fully, fully in.
Letting go.
After the exhalation, stop.
And when you feel the urge to breathe,
it's no competition,
you take 'em in fully,
let's do it all.
Fully in, hold.
10 seconds and squeeze
it, push it to the head
to bring in more oxygen in the brain stem.
Five, four, three, two, one.
And we let go.
Okay, breathing exercise number two,
they call it power breathing.
Fully breathe, come on.
Fully in, go.
Fully in.
Go.
Fully in, go.
Five, four, three, two, one,
Fully in, fully out,
and now, full in, and lock.
Contract abdomen, chest, neck,
now, your head, squeeze.
Three, two, one, let it go.
- [Students] Ah.
- We got to do a pushup exercise.
For those, for those, for
those, who have an inflammatory
condition like arthritis or
MS or anything like that,
could be Crohn's, anything,
you do it after inhalation.
Pushups after inhalation.
Brings down inflammatory markers, zoom.
This one brings you,
resets you in four minutes.
So four minutes exercise.
You can do it any time of the day.
Fully in, let it go.
Three, two, one, here it comes,
Stop after exhalation.
Pushups, no breathing, just go.
Astound yourself.
This is what I do with
people who could not even do
one pushup, suddenly,
they are able to do 20.
Amazing.
This is the magic.
And it's you.
(cheering)
That's you, guys.
It's good luck.
Ha.
Yeah, man, we can climb any mountain.
- [Man] Okay, so we're going
to take a little break.
We're going to have some wraps for lunch,
there's going to be some
more snacks coming out soon.
So feel free to meet some new friends,
enjoy yourselves, and we'll let you know
when we're going to start
the second half, okay?
- [Wim] Great work!
- So that was pretty epic, guys.
I've never had a lot
of success meditating,
that's actually something
I complained about,
or just was worried about,
never got a good chance
to meditate, I never felt it.
But this, for the first time,
I was in a different zone,
my fingers are still
tingling from doing it,
and I've been practicing at home
but never to that extent,
so I got a really good tool.
The speech was awesome, but just the last,
however long that was,
I kind of spaced out,
was worth the price of admission,
and so I'm really pumped
to get in the water,
I was kind of doubting, but after that,
I'm feeling pretty good,
and also continue in the habit,
so we're going to have some
lunch and then get back to it.
(upbeat music)
- I'm a normal guy, simple guy,
but I'm going to change the world.
I lost my wife in 95,
was alone with four children, no money.
The only thing I found relief in
was in cold water and breathing exercises.
Just a hunch.
And I did it.
(clapping)
Just a reconnect with the body
and use your mind to become
happy, strong, and healthy.
Those are the most essential in the life,
then the rest will subdue.
Just think about it.
Let it sink.
And if you come up with any
difficulty or this or that,
know from now on that you
are able to tackle it.
They told me, he's crazy, he's
idiot, he's this and that.
But he's not sane, he is
not okay, don't believe him.
Now it's science.
What was the difference?
Just keep at it.
Keep on believing that
happiness, strength,
and health is natural.
Instead of cancer and autoimmune
diseases and depression
and that thinking that that is normal,
I think it is sick.
And it should not be
here with us, no longer.
From here we part ways.
We become sane, strong, and happy.
And rest out of the way, where it belongs.
Not inside, outside.
Gone.
And that's love, to each other.
(cheering)
That's love, yes, good.
So the ice is there.
I can see that with my eyes.
Yeah, right on.
This is my daughter, Halora.
(speaking in a foreign language)
- Oh, say in English?
- Well, the ice is melting,
normally, I would say.
- Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Let's go up and then everybody
is going to, you know,
you're going to go in the ice,
is like this, you stand around the pool,
at ease, just follow the breath.
You go in (breathes) then you sit down,
you lay down up till your neck,
put your hands on the thighs,
tight, to induce the warmth,
and then relax, control.
Control.
Slow down.
(upbeat music)
(grunting)
Okay, thank you, thank you.
(cheering and clapping)
Health, happiness, strength, is ours.
Pass it down, pass it on.
Okay.
Good.
- So yeah, so I just want to say thank you
on behalf of myself and
everyone here in Canada
- Thanks, guys.
- For your severe sense
as someone who has a fierce
compassion to change the world,
breaks down any doors, never
says no, sacrifices himself
so that guys, (speaking in a
foreign language) warm round
of applause for Wim, thank you so much.
- [Wim] Yes.
- So we are done, it is, what
time is it, five o'clock?
- It is 4:35.
- Four, the dog's trying to get away.
- He's kind of distracting,
he's trying to get away.
- It's been an all day thing,
they clean up pretty quickly.
What did you, what did
you take away from this?
What did you learn?
- I learned that I'm
stronger than I think.
- High five for that.
Good job, Nina.
- I will never imagine myself
to sit in that cold bath,
ice bath, for that long.
- So now, now when the air
conditioning's on at night
and we're going to sleep,
say, oh, that's nothing,
we should turn the air
conditioning up even, even higher.
- No, just don't depend now, I don't like
the air blowing on my face.
- But look what you just sat in.
- But that's different.
- That's ice water.
(laughing)
I like a colder room than Nina does.
I had a really good time,
I met a lot of fans here, which is good,
probably around a dozen different fans.
- Yes.
- Some from entrepreneurial
content and also some
people watched the two
other videos we did on
Wim and his techniques,
some people, actually
a number of people said
that the first video that
we did that has a million
views now, was their
first introduction to Wim
and the reason why they came here,
so that was really cool,
really cool to see.
Lots of fun people, lots of good wisdom.
We're going to breathe,
we're going to breathe daily?
- Yeah, every morning.
- We're going to breathe daily?
- We're going to have our--
- Pinkie promise?
- We're going to have our morning ritual.
- To involve the breathing?
- Yeah.
- Okay, good.
Well, thank you guys for watching,
hope you enjoyed our journey with us,
and go check out the Wim Hof Method.
I highly recommend it, and
it's already allowed me
not to be sick for almost six months,
and looking forward to what happens,
now that Nina and I are
going to do it together.
Good couple therapy, too.
Thank you guys for watching.
- Continue to believe.
- You have to say we believe in you.
- Oh, we believe in you.
And continue to believe.
We'll see you soon.
Much love.
- Aim whatever.
- And whatever you on where is.
- Much love.
- We'll see you soon.
(laughing)